bon ça va mieux le titre i am et beuvron
charbon soir oui c'est noël savent
écrire ça va alors je suis très heureux
de connaître
j'ai vu la vie sexuelle des belges un
grand moment tu fais la belle la vie des
belges de la wii compris cosmos away se
sent plus gratiné la première or ce
n'était des belges
camping l'avoir vue vers alors la cdas
culte surtout nous elle est bien il ya
aussi de la les photos nous l'alef des
les bêtes bière artisanale explosif
on ne trouve pas ici bien quand même la
duvel la boisson de prédilection benoît
poelvoorde cette arrivée patchage ces
diables en irlande et visage là je la
recommande il est où le garçon là où
vous pouvez appeler le tenant sied babel
tenant série voudrez si s'initiait la
duvel comment tu dis la duvel la duvel
bonsoir est-ce que je peux avoir de la
duvel alors de la leffe automnaux l'alef
automnaux d'accord
oui
[Musique]
voilà n'arrivait pas de masse
ça non
qui c'est celui-là
on dirait que ces pannes dis moi c'est
le dernier que 30 artistes qui là
c'était alors le tout dernier ça s'est
passé à cannes le jan faisait partie de
l'opération
c'est le dernier deux camps du plan tir
parfait pour nous représente vraiment la
production cinématographique dans toute
son horreur dans toute sa prétention je
connais son côté marvin seck et nous ne
voulions que lui à cannes c'était depuis
le départ nous voulions absolument tout
ce qu'en dit quand vous l'avez alors
nous l'attendions en fait on avait
appris par des retraites dans son
entourage parce que depuis quelques
temps c'est toujours d'être être d'un
tout âge de la victime qui nous
renseigne on avait appris qu'il devait
déjeuner au majestic
on l'attend on note une vingtaine avec
des équipes photo caméra il ne vient pas
suite à des troubles de ce tome accuse d
comment dès lors on organise une
véritable chasse à courre au toscan
comme et ont déambulé à travers cannes
avec nos équipes on veut que ce camp où
le rap on apprend le gibier localisé
dans le palais des festivals au niveau 4
il est au salon des ambassadeurs nous
montons petit à petit des trucs le
système se trouve une quarantaine on
entend des îles waltz quand allons les
aider
et au moment où on monte toscan du
plantier vie qui descend il va nous
échapper
il s'engage sur l'escalator mécanique de
m'élancer pas du tout avant je me lance
à sa poursuite tarte à la main au moment
je compte l entarté en dessous de
l'escalator mécanique mais un garde de
corps m'attrape peu mais ceinture je me
dégage
souplement je suis déséquilibré je
bascule d'un avis je donc droit à ce
qu'un du plantier au milieu des
escalators et nous roulons jusqu'en bas
des marches enroulé est amplement l'un à
l'autre pendant la roulette jeunes en
tête en bas des marches je me relève et
je m'écris entartons entartons les
quantifiant croûtons non sur ceux celles
à l'ept nasa génial génial j'ai été là
pour moi pour s'occuper de notre
protection à riffa sont tombés dans
tarte est aussi bon milan prônent second
est une jeune flibustière lui en relief
une troisième
il en avait partout le matériel est
l'imbécile aux yeux de ceux qui étaient
considérés non c'est qu'au lieu d'aller
se débarbouiller aux toilettes
ils se dirigeaient ont totalement
inondée de chantilly vers la lumière de
la croisette
il est apparu la l'eau naturellement
sous les machines par une grosse partie
de la foule a applaudi la belle
charlotte juste blazy tu l'as fait aussi
non depuis quand ses débuts dans sa
musique band années précédentes
en fait comme avait été arraisonné par
les services d'ordre c'est
jan bucquoy mais qui s'en est occupé
dont jeune fille bus tiens ça marche
mais aussi lui mais bon tabassé par les
gardes du corps de procès deux procès
deux procès gagné contre l'état français
ah bon parce que l'on fait on peut
entarté les nazis vous attaquez les
plaintes avant des plaintes est en fait
la justice nous a donné raison ça deux
fois puis ce qu'ils ont fait on a le
droit d'en ternon pour emporter les
ministres impunément
c'est génial c'est bon à savoir mais je
s'expliquer que finalement l' entartage
est une vieille tradition belge depuis
l'acquisition
donc même les magasins des plus loin à
une big and at the gate art chez breguet
c'est bien connu c'est qu'en fait c'est
un honneur de recevoir une tarte
évidemment tafer bpm si j'ai mal aux
aléas oui ça faisait longtemps que je
voulais la voir que rien mais justement
ça faisait un moment que tu en parles
est un de nos principes c'est d'attendre
que des victimes sont vraiment en
position de force
ce qui fait que très patiemment la
ranger notre faim et on attendu que
pedro vianna
voilà tout à fait qu'on était bien sûr
on le sait depuis quelques motocyclistes
silva dans ses moindres faits et gestes
pour portables non non non non non et
bien sûr les jeunes filles d'aller chez
eux avec un filet vous veniez me lécher
voluptueusement karim bien doubler chez
karine tient bien c'est ça voilà et tout
de suite les jeunes filles nous lèche
après mademoiselle k reen voulez vous
aussi me lécher un paiement sepa sepa
tour voit des avantages ferrique le
faisan d'agression tout à fait bonhomme
est inévitable on est léchée eric
manches et nous avons donc non les
choses de service et puis quoi c'est un
copain depuis longtemps alors dans deux
buts depuis que ses ventes contre il ya
quelques années on ne sait quasiment
plus quitté sa vraie lui ce un vrai
révolutionnaire jan
deschamps le savez c'est le mot que
paraître ridicule mais j'aime beaucoup
ce mot comme aux 68 à peu près des
cultes et à vrai dire on agite hâte de
choc sur qui on peut compter et un truc
avec l'art henrianne c'est qu'en france
si tu veux moi je suis royaliste
c'est très subversif des trois listes en
france nommé en belgique c'est au
contraire c'est le cas c'est décapité
beaudoin des subversifs archives royales
c'est un mot qui seraient manipulés donc
je sais pas donc c'est toi qui le dit
mais moi je crois que je suis un mot la
vie chouette
oui c'est cette même femme née en moi je
suis pour la vie une transaction
complète et globale et c'est sûr que ce
n'est ni les élections bon s'il xc les
élections c'est pour les français
pouvaient changer la société entend
qu'elle serait interdite
ouais je sais quoi donc sert en prenant
les armes en égorgeant tous les
bougeoirs et en prenant leur place qu'on
change l'allemande mais avec les
théories les bouquins sur l'énergie
autre chose on changera jamais rien des
bibliothèques sont pleines de grandes
idées et qu'on joue on voit ce que
j'avais fait part à l'insurrection bien
sûr et pour moi c'est en 2005 le vin qui
remet donc j'appellerais le bon peuple
de bruxelles de me suivre et que mon
temps que sherman qui se trouve au musée
de l'armée ici en belgique et qui est
prêt - des kits mandela s'est elle sera
sera un putsch à protéger les
dénonciateurs ouais bah non pas créer
dans les sous sols
quand imachin nom raymond annoncé
pendant des années et est donc vraiment
le vainqueur mais j'attends tous les
bruxellois et peut-être même les
parisiens s'explique comment que la
transgression soit réfugié en belgique
pour peut-être parce que nous avons pas
eu une image de notre idiome identité
globale celui en français c'est un
française avec un quelqu'un de
prétentieux
c'est tous les soirs comme ça je sais
pas c'est pas vraiment
bravo on avait commandé cent mille tard
non c'est lui qui attaque solide une
c'est peut-être la vie de baudouin fabio
la soirée ne sais pas
c'est magnifique
nous devrons à museler ben ali les
nouveaux alors bon c'est pas un roi bien
sûr puisqu'il tremblay y roule en moto
donc c'est assez beau doigt un beaudoin
c'était le dernier roi puisqu'il avait
il y avait 40 ont de bons ils baissaient
pas on pouvait pas l'imaginer baiser et
donc c'était une espèce de st d'ailleurs
je compte bientôt déterré son cadavre
pour vendre les reliques
qu'est-ce que tu l'avais décapité son
buste avait été arrêté ça a été dur pour
toi ça a été dur puisque en fait les
rois sont des images quelques jours sur
sept lycées des icônes sont des images
dont été on peut projeter tous nos
désirs toutes nos appels aux pères mères
eternal si tu veux et dès qu'on abîme
l'image et sait combien la vie mais bien
sûr le roi puisque le vent est devenue
une image
donc c'est le sacré c'est le vrai
pouvoir une amende ça va pouvoir sacré a
été en prison
une nuit seulement puisque disons que
moi je j'emploie l'art comme une espèce
de conceptualisation de la révolution de
la tacc donc ce que je fais c'est par
exemple quand je vais attaquer que mon
mentor
c'est un concept un chairman donc depuis
longtemps vous expose d'api sherman donc
si tu veux mais bon il ya aussi
l'introduction de l'humour
continuellement puisque comme dit lacan
l'humour anil de sur moi qui ai les
censeurs
soit intello ses dettes non mais pour
revenir à la belgique je crois qu'on n'a
pas cette prétention des allemands des
anglais
donc on a une espèce d'identité qui est
quand même fissuré qui est pas donc on
peut se moquer de nous mêmes et je crois
que c'est ça notre force finalement r d
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus